dana was uh my boxing coach when i was
when i was a teenager i remember
uh sparring him he was telling me like i
want you to try and [ __ ] kill him and
i was like okay
okay so i connected with them
clean as hard as i could with my right
hand he just was like
that's what i'm talking about and then
just started wiping me out
hey i'm rashad evans and i'm on hot
boxing with mike tyson
and bj [ __ ] baldwin what's the deal
brother
what's going on i don't know we want to
hear about your record-breaking stunts
man
hello we also want to know about your
fancy
entrepreneurship with the gun oh thank
you would you do that
because i saw one time i didn't mean to
interrupt you that sammy davis jr
and um rob might notice when he's just
sitting around with the gun and shooting
pow pow
pow pow putting it back in and you do
all that stuff
uh put it back in the hose and pull it
out not really a trickster
sammy davis used to like mess with guns
really i didn't know that i have to out
to check that out i'm uh
been in off-road racing long-distance
endurance endurance racing
in the desert for a little over 20 years
now i've got uh
seven series points championship i'm the
only person to win the baja one thousand
two consecutive years and drive the
entire distance i'll fall with that no
yeah it's really far come on give the
number oh man it was uh
1160 miles in 2012.
i was in the car for 20 hours and 15
minutes and then the following year
i think it was like 930 miles and i was
in the car for about
16 hours when i'm in the car that long
you know what happens i catch this
this illness what is it called again the
sciatica sciatica i can't walk you got
to get an operation yeah
really yeah wow no i don't i'm in the
seat that wrong
operation isn't that crazy i get really
tired i mean i think the the biggest
thing for me
is uh the mental fatigue you know
because it's like one thing
we only in the baja 1000 you only get
1967 was i think its origination but you
only get to see this
uh the same corner one time as it
relates to
like other forms of racing you do laps
and baha 1000 is one
thousand mile lap so you get one
opportunity to do everything
but it's so preeminent because they made
stories like sammy davis junior and demo
and did that one
yeah was that show called something 500
the baja 500 i think they did i think
they did do some racing back
then there's a wild wild world something
to that effect it was the same way you
know every
crazy person was on this race to get
something of what it was
it was so long now we love kids you're
doing those drives how many people you
got driving with you
uh well i got uh i got my navigator and
then uh
for most of the uh baja 1000's
that i've done i've driven the entire
distance
it's the rate yeah
yeah it's a it's off-road race there's
about 300
cars and trucks and motorcycles there's
probably 40 of them
uh in my class in the unlimited class
which is the class that you have any
great women with drivers
participating into the race yeah there's
a there's a few there's a few good
women drivers sarah price is in the uh
spec truck
class um but yeah it's it's
super super competitive it's uh my truck
is basically
everything that you can put into
something that looks like a truck and
make it go
really really fast over a really rough
desert
it's makes about 950 horsepower
uh it'll go through three and four foot
bumps at 115 miles
um what makes the categories you said
yours and unlimited so like what makes
the
different categories where they are well
they'll have like a rule book
for all these uh various classes like
we'll take
i think it's class nine it's been so
long um
they'll have or like a stock full truck
will have to have
stock suspension arms stock size shocks
have to run uh stock frame rails
and then have to have like an engine
that's similar to stock and then
everything else can be upgraded so that
that rule books like 25 pages of all the
stuff
that has to be put into that truck to
make sure it qualifies
a real competitive truck about 850 000
really
yeah my my rule book is one page it's
gotta
have a factory uh
production grill and have uh factory
looking lights but they're just stickers
everything else is open there's really
not much what's the fatality rate with
this stuff anybody ever died
doing this yeah people people die you
know occasionally
at the bahama 1000 people get hurt all
the time
a couple people die every year at the
bottom thousands it's pretty dangerous
i try not to die it's not fun i've been
on fire six times i've
i've uh i my
navigator missed a note in 2015
and i was trying to pass somebody in the
dust at two in the morning
and i flew off a cliff into a rock the
size of a school bus and i went from i
was going 96 miles an hour on the road
and i got it slowed down to about 71.72
miles an hour i went from
70 miles an hour to zero in about
15 inches so before you do this whole
thing like
you and your crews you guys are out
navigating the whole the whole course
and making sure you get every single
little nuance and
i can't even fathom what you said to me
just now
i was trying to think about what you
told me and i'm gonna think 15 inches
he's getting mad
like a fatal car crash from like a
regular production vehicle
is like 33 miles an hour
you know so if i didn't have my
five-point harnesses on and then i have
a head and neck restraint that keeps
uh keeps me from having basilar skull
fracture where
the base of your brain breaks in your in
your brain stem
if i didn't have that would be dead at
half that speed so there's a lot of
protective equipment but
you know you're still why you want to do
stuff like that
it's it's another dimension
in motor sports like there's one thing
it's one thing to like go around a track
and you have a bunch of
people watching and it's on tv and you
get you know
500 opportunities to hit this corner or
that corner what not but
when you have all of these elements that
you can't control
like rock wall on the left and 100 foot
cliff on the right or a blind
uh jump um yeah it's
it's pretty plus passing the 100 foot
cliff
you don't think about like passing in a
desert race
you don't get to see much because
there's explosive dust
uh you know in front of you from the car
that you're trying to chase down so
it definitely adds another what made you
say this is what i want to do
the first time you say wow i want to do
this
i always liked driving cars you know
like
i learned how to drive a car when i was
six years old i stole my sister's
corvette when i was
nine years old and drove around the
neighborhood for you know about 15-20
minutes i got in a little bit of trouble
for that but
uh i always liked racing and
i was really really good on on dirt
bikes
when i was a kid and i got an
opportunity to race with the
barbary coast team in like a small
limited production
buggy and then it just evolved into uh
trophy truck racing
how many trucks do you have yeah how
about that
i got uh personally personally
well i got uh a dodge diesel
i've got loki which is a 1978
chevy blazer that's fully built out like
a like a pre-runner but it has a motor
that's a lot smaller it runs on pump gas
it makes about 600 horsepower
it's got lots and lots of wheel travel i
really enjoy driving that
and then i have six support trucks two
pre-runners
and two race trucks now the one that see
i knew bj for a while
my me and mj go back for a while and uh
how you know him b.j
i know i'm through mutual friends yeah
mutual friends that's one thing that
sticks to my memory when those guys were
like
they were like messing with you or
something what club was it we were at
the
dre's or something like that oh yeah
nothing i'm like dude
isn't that terrifying he was doing that
to these guys
in the elevator that were trying to get
tough with him at dre's at that monster
party
and i was like [ __ ] these guys have no
idea they didn't know who he was and
they were trying to get tough i'm like
dude he will
vaporize you and then thankfully you had
that bark so you didn't have to do it
soon as soon as he barked at him the guy
pushed the button in the elevator and
the door started
him i was scared back from
my wife
yeah so i went riding with him one time
and it was uh um
it was an experience because it felt as
if like we was completely out of control
but the way he would move and shift in
the car you knew he was in control
but there are some times that
[ __ ] you gotta ride out of here
no you gotta ride with him you gotta
ride with him i'm telling you
it changed
so so i was i was talking to rob about
uh getting you in the truck and
he was he was saying that you're like no
[ __ ] that i'm not going
and i try to explain it and maybe you
can explain it better
when i get out of first gear and go into
second gear
the fear is gone because of the stuff
that you're hitting
and at the speed that you're hitting it
it goes well beyond
fear you just start to try and
comprehend how is this happening and why
is this not breaking my back and jarring
my teeth out and
how is it going this fast so you don't
stay it feels
like more like einstein than a truck
driver okay
i don't know i can't follow this [ __ ] i
mean
like a two wheels and just the obstacles
he was able to hit
get around and like you know how like
you got those oh [ __ ] moments when
you're driving
it seemed like he may have had those but
you wouldn't even be able to tell
because it was just cool as a cook
cucumber just like moving
moving that thing's slow actually that's
scared of accidents and [ __ ] i'm always
saying praying before i get in the car
to go home or getting on the plane
bj man i gotta take you for riding the
racetrack someday because that
compared to that is crazy that's too
much excitement for me man
you'll go i'll talk you don't even feel
the bumps though do you you don't really
feel the bumps
no no bombs they got a shock suspension
on those on the car that you just like
you feel like you're floating my shocks
are like as tall as him this big around
i've got six
i can imagine mother needs to have those
pickup trucks needs to crash each other
and all that stuff
yeah was that for a commercial no it was
real stuff it was the
competition oh it was uh oh the derby
the dirt did you have the derby to derby
and one was named monster you know that
name for that
yeah man so that this will make you a
little bit more
comfortable like take like an average
really big truck
i can t-bone that truck in my race truck
at 70 miles an hour and back up and
drive around it there
would not be any damage to my truck at
all that's how strong they are
now how many times are you driving i
might not be that strong i'm making
[ __ ] particles over here and over
here my brain
shaving my heart i'll be [ __ ] all right
you'll be done
no how many times are you driving and
you you're on like one of these uh
these baja races and you had like this
oh my god i felt like i just
that was almost it for me uh it's very
very rare
i like to make sure if i'm doing that
the juice is worth the squeeze so if i
have to make a certain amount of time
yeah for sure because you know it's it's
if i'm
operating at a hundred percent of my
ability that's not really fun for me
i would i would rather you know
i like and you could probably relate to
this as it relates to fighting
um i like to
beat people that are really well known
in embarrassing fashion like that's
fun but being in like
you know a vehicular fist fight for 300
miles for
several several hours with one of the
best guys in the world
and then beating their ass that's not
fun during the time that that's
happening
because i have to take a substantial
amount of risk but afterwards
like that moment you know never never
leaves me because
i remember how much risk i took what i
got away with
you know as it relates to calculated
risk and that i beat
some of the best guys in the world you
know
often you being an athlete and
anticipating things
that sounds like you're juggling with
your ego there too yeah so talk about
your interest in it though
interest in uh racing none and um in the
psychedelics you said you were
interested in doing it
well you know i've never i've never done
anything like that
and a lot of my well not a lot of my
sponsors one of my sponsors in
particular
feels a certain way about about
marijuana and drugs in general so
i can either confirm or deny that i've
ever done anything but i hear
and i believe that marijuana
is a performance enhancing drug in
addition to being a recreation
i've done uh competitive jiu-jitsu
competitive juicer for 15 years and i
train with some of them
some really really good fighters i
talked to you about that but i i would
have never
gotten my purple belt if it wasn't for
you know some help from some stuff that
you're involved in
yeah i've just i never had um a
respectable
relationship with my ego yeah
and to do that is just man it's like
breathtaking
yeah i'll definitely have to look into
that i've been thinking about a lot this
last year because i see rogan talk about
it i've seen you talk about it with
rogan a bunch of times
yeah it's been it's been uh it's been a
crazy year
but like throughout this whole year just
got your mind just thinking that
i want to know oh yeah
somebody tried to murder my girlfriend
and i
it's disgusting he either talked about
it
no no it doesn't bother me uh really
at all you know the person i i didn't
know him it was like a really
strange thing um
you know we were in a parking lot
getting some dinner and
two guys like speed walking
you know walked up on uh tori and i my
girlfriend
and one of them had a gun pointed at
torrey and uh
didn't ask for money or anything and
started a gunfight you know so and uh
of course i've been doing you know
defensive tactics and lethal force
turned out really cool but i'm really
sad at the press already i forgot the
[ __ ]
this guy does this thing so
uh the the dude was like you know
really a big big guy he's probably an
inch taller than me he probably
outweighed me by like 80 pounds
um he's really excited about uh
the opportunity to murder both of us
that's what
kind of i got the impression from um
and and i he started shooting at
you know tori and and me oh time
time time he started shooting at you
yeah well i wasn't going to let him get
any closer to
torrey so and he had he had the gun out
the whole time
didn't make any demands or anything like
that
and i assumed that he was going to uh
engage her for whatever reason
and that's when
stuff started popping off and we got in
a gunfight he shot at tory twice
shot at me six times and uh
you know i shot him in the face from 25
yards away
so you do a lot of the defensive tactics
stuffs and training and stuff like that
so how much of that was just like
just training it was very unfair
it was very unfair because you know i'm
i'm as far as i know i'm one of two guys
in the country that can
draw a gun from concealment and gauge a
target
five yards uh and put four rounds on
target in under a second so i could draw
and put four rounds on target in under a
second
i do a lot of balance of speed and
accuracy and
very very high level high proficiency
uh defensive tactics training from
concealed carry with with a pistol so
i'm
really really good with uh with a
handgun my girlfriend tori's got i don't
know
20 world championship titles and
competitive pistol shootings so
we do a lot of that
so for somebody to
try and murder us with a handgun in a
parking lot
i don't think that they saw that coming
it was really really unfair for them but
i wasn't gonna
let them murder my girlfriend and myself
i was just out trying to have a
hamburger you know
yeah so but uh i
honestly i don't feel one way or the
other about it i wish it never happened
but if
if it had to happen like we were saying
about talking to god that's be the
question i would ask because
i didn't have any fear i didn't have any
anxiety
you know wasn't worried i just saw a
problem that needed to be solved
and that's not characteristic yeah
that's
you know in in my mind it's almost
like you know that was a
part of a plan or some some type because
we were in a good part of town you know
wasn't a lot of crime or anything in
that part of town and we're just
having a hamburger somebody's started
shooting at tory and i
and unfortunately for them they
picked a gun fight with two people that
know a whole lot about
gun fights so now since that whole
situation happened
i bet you're training with the defensive
tactics is a lot more
it's a lot different when you approach
the situation it's just not training
anymore right
yeah it's it it has changed me quite a
bit i've increased my proficiency of the
firearm
more than i ever thought i would um i've
been studying
uh ballistics for nine months
um and testing all different types of
ammunition different bullets i had
bullets fail in that particular
exchange and they didn't perform how i
thought they
would have um i thought they'd be able
to solve the problem a little bit
better i through this uh
exchange i didn't think i'd be i'd have
to fire more than like two rounds to get
this person to stop
shooting um but i had to fire
uh 10 rounds which was very very
surprising
bullet selection for somebody that's a
concealed carry
holder is super super important and it's
not something a lot of people talk about
or know a lot about
you want something like if somebody's
trying to like in our case
you know somebody's trying to murder you
for whatever reason
um you'd want to have the tools and the
fuel in your platform
to solve the problem as quickly as
possible
you know um but yeah i've i've learned a
lot
and uh it's been kind of a crazy 10
months
thinking about it have you been able to
like package that knowledge up and kind
of like
share it with people as far as like on
the seminar basis point of view type of
thing or what
uh not not quite yet there's still
i i don't want to do that until i know
everything that there is to know you
know so like
for example one thing that nobody thinks
about uh
velocity of a bullet so i had a bullet
that was supposed
supposed to perform very well velocity
wasn't
exceptional it was very slow for a
bullet and
while i was being engaged and she was
being engaged
there was a lot of movement taking place
and at 14 yards
my bullet didn't get there before the
threat
moved out of the way so seven to ten
inches off point and aim point of impact
at 970 feet per second
yeah i got a little bit better bullets
now my bullets are for
concealed carry and for some of the
people that i've
gone to classes with and help
well i got four four different types
what's the best one uh depends on the
application
so ideally like 45 that's too slow
ideally you'd want something that
can stop somebody that is trying to
attack or murder you or has presenting
lethal force
with the knowledge that that projectile
is going to perform
inside of a certain depth of
of threats tissue right and not exceed
that
if if you're exceeding that not only are
you wasting kinetic energy
but now that projectile has passed
through that person well who's behind
them they might
they might not be somebody that's with
them it might be in a crowded place so
you don't ever want to
accidentally strike somebody that's not
involved an innocent person or something
like that so a lot goes into bullet
design to make sure that
you know police officers use some uh
pretty good stuff but it's
definitely not the best so i've learned
i've done a lot of math up here
as it relates to that [ __ ] no good [ __ ]
yeah so that
shows the specialties you got the the
specialties with the driving but just as
much your specialist with the drive
you are with the firearms and the
education that goes along with it
yeah you know it's the same thing with
everything like
you know your world champion your world
champion i'm world champion if you put
that
bandwidth into whatever else like
baking a cake if you were really like
[ __ ] up on some [ __ ] like i want to
make the best [ __ ] cake
you know in the world and you dedicated
six months on
like baking that cake your cake would be
bomb right
you know because you know how to get
there because you're already you're both
already you know
world champ multi-time world champions
so it takes that
mindset to get everything figured out
and
find every possible avenue to gain an
advantage in performance
so yeah there's a lot to go there's a
lot that goes into it it's been pretty
interesting journey just listening
you'd be amazed what my neighbors don't
hear and i can neither can
confirm or deny where my test facility
is but right you got to have a lot of
land somewhere where you can just you
know
you should i mean i i've seen have you
seen
it right man you shoot the gun the
bullets come off so
it looks like it's spray looks like mist
yeah
you see those guys look like mess like
yeah yeah dylan m134
the one with the six barrels
they're fun how many guns do you own
because i've seen you have quite a
collection honestly i haven't counted in
a
while
i've been building uh i've been building
like pistols just like uh modifying
glock pistols and building like
a really really high performing um
glock pistols probably built like five
or six of them in the last 10 months
just do you build them yourself yeah you
start with the
factory glock and then do a bunch of
grip modifications and select different
barrel
uh types and optics and light
lighting uh laser combinations and
making a perfect gun pretty much very
well tuned yeah i'm strictly um i'm
anti-gun
but i believe some [ __ ] do need to
be shot
yeah i'm anti-gun too that's why i carry
a gun
some people you can't help with the
shooter
no yeah you're right about that man
i only believe the theater but just in
real life
it's just like that yeah there's some
people that are
you know inherently evil and then
there's some people that are maybe
psychologically wounded
i'm not gonna let you warn me because
you're saying yeah
yeah hold off on that psychological blue
tiger
how many i'm curious how many
uh altercations do you think you've been
in
in the last 10 years does anybody ever
try and mess with you or anything
yeah i can't fight oh how does that go
because i'm like
i'm always like you know like uh dana
was uh
my boxing coach when i was when i was a
teenager and then i got into jiu jitsu
and stuff like that and i've
i've sparked some people that you know
are not
dana white yeah i'm sorry dana white
yeah yeah oh
did you know that you know i didn't know
that he was your boxing she was a boxing
trainer kickboxing trainer
uh no just like regular boxers boxing
training yeah
yeah when i was eighteen nineteen twenty
how was the other yeah
right oh man you remember like tito
and him were supposed to yeah yeah
i man i don't know you know i i like
tito but
dana's got hands dana's got hands oh
she's got hair
dana got here you know what dennis
strike me as somebody got hands because
he's got a confidence with him like
like i wish a [ __ ] would kind of
confidence you know what i'm saying he's
got hands
and he's got granite in his i remember
uh sparring him i probably sparked him
like i don't know 10 or 15 times but
i remember one time in particular i was
feeling like really feeling myself like
i was like
really crisp really fast you know for
just
you know regular guy because i've been
training so much
and he would always just wipe me out
when we would when we would spar he'd be
nice but then he would you know he'd
bust me oh he's like
why would you he spar with
i remember i i caught him like slipping
a certain way as
you know just caught like some behavior
and i knew where he was gonna go when i
was gonna slip
and you know i wasn't i wasn't a good
boxer by any means or even mediocre but
i could hit
really [ __ ] hard especially with my
right hand and i remember where
i thought that he was gonna try and slip
to if i feigned it
and i tagged him like as hard as i could
with my because he was telling me like i
know you love me stop [ __ ] around
you know i want you to try and [ __ ]
kill me i was like okay
okay so i connected with them clean
as hard as i could with my right hand
hard enough to where like
my elbow hurt and like my shoulder hurt
i hit him
because he was moving in at the same
time and
he just was like that's what i'm talking
about and then just started
wiping me out no he's
really tough really really tough guys
wow that was so bad
going with russia's story i'm sorry that
dana park just caught me just by
surprise
so i've had a a series of events
from the time i was a teenager
to when my son was born so i've had like
i've had like death threats i've i've
been at a
party where a fight broke out i got shot
at i've had
you know guns pulled on me and my
friends this is when i was younger so i
don't know
like not many people have all that stuff
happen
you know to to to them but i had always
you know been a good shooter and i got
my concealed carry permit when i was 21
and i started
you know training here and there and
then i had an event with my son
where some guys were trying to run me
off the road and yelling at me a bunch
of guys in this truck i had no idea what
it was about
and i was you know i was scared i was
like what is this
what is going on and i had uh
i was like well i'm bj baldwin i'll just
drive away like nobody's going to catch
me
and i was in a truck that had a big
motor in it and i was just going to rip
through traffic and go through the
desert and leave these guys
well i didn't have any gas i'd like no
range left on on on the
fuel gauge and i was like [ __ ] okay well
man this is like charles brosten and
dennis denzel washington
equalizers
in that instance you know i had my
gun on my other car and i had uh my son
with me he was a year old i was taking
him to lunch
then you got the [ __ ] you got your
[ __ ] kid in danger
man i know i know so i had no idea what
this was about
does this [ __ ] always just come to you
like the dangerous [ __ ] does your like
spidey sense of the game
i don't know i wish it didn't i wish it
didn't but yeah i
i had my gun in my other car because i
thought
i don't know what this was about there's
like four or five people in this car and
they were yelling telling me they were
gonna kill me
it's like damn they're pretty upset i
ended up making it to this restaurant
and running my son
in i like sprinted to the restaurant and
ran my son and they
came in behind me and i came out
to deal with it i gave my son to the
hostess and i came out to to deal with
it
and the guy was like super apologetic
he's like oh my god i'm so sorry i
didn't know you had your son with you
and um you know i was
behind you and there was a little rock
that fell off and it broke my windshield
and i'm sorry i've had a
really bad day and i shouldn't have
freaked out like that
and uh but after that you know
because you know in my younger days i
might have
gotten out of the car you know and and
been like yo what's up
um and tried to deal with it i could
have gotten knocked out my son would
have been
in there in my truck exposed to
you know the heat or something like that
he could have he could have gotten hurt
so i was just trying to get away
and then after that i just started i
started doing a lot of
defensive tactics training and i never
left home without my gun after that
because because of my kids i just
it rattled around in my head like that
could have gone
way south you could have you know they
could have ran you off the road
killed your son or something these
people had me really really
uh concerned and i was helpless there's
nothing i could do but i had
no fuel usually i would just drive away
right right you know what
what [ __ ] that wants to run you off
the road is going to catch a world
champion driver like who's going to
knock you out in the club
nobody they punch in the face they'll
die no that's probably true but i don't
give them the chance that they're not
going to hit them first
who doesn't even say anything
disrespectful
do you remember going to jet night club
in 2008
this is definitely something that would
be good for the podcast those are my
savage years yeah
oh yeah me and my [ __ ] hey let me
stop
yeah that's pretty interesting let's jet
jet with the ninth club
did how did you go there a few times or
just oh that i've lived there that's my
home
that's my living room yeah yeah
that was mine too i knew like a bunch of
people to club so that was that's a
really good story i don't know if i ever
told you the story is here
i wouldn't know this is [ __ ] great so
my my son's mother
and i were having this crazy fight you
know
he'll have close scoring no no it was
actually before and i was eating dinner
at yellowtail
at bellagio with a couple my couple of
my friends
and these punks came up behind
and they were like pushing people uh
you know around um like through the
crowd of
bellagio like some some bullies and i
was with
two like really really tough guys that
were friends of mine my buddy jason and
my buddy dip
and i saw this happen and i was like
[ __ ] this is perfect and i pointed them
out
to them because i was like you know
these guys
if i kicked their [ __ ] ass it would
be doing them a huge
favor right you know if they got embarra
three of them got embarrassed by one guy
and i got my two buddies to back me up
if you know if i have any problems
so i followed them over uh i made sure
they stayed like 20 yards back so it
looked like i was all alone and i
followed these three guys across the
overpass on flamingo
and they picked up one of the you know
the guy that plays the guitar for like a
couple of some cheeses
yeah so he picked up the guy's hat one
of them picked up the guy's hat and
threw it into traffic
and i was like oh dude i'm gonna have so
many [ __ ] shows
and death wish go ahead so much fun with
these guys
so i went down i followed you got a
little closer i went to you
i love this [ __ ] so i went up the the
next escalator and i made sure i didn't
i got up close i made sure i didn't say
anything while i was on the escalator
because i just get
stomped down the escalator i'm like
plotting all this [ __ ] out
so we get to the top of the escalator
and i says with all the three of these
guys and i says
i'm i'm here and they turn around and
says who the [ __ ] are you
so i thought you were looking for me and
so who the [ __ ] are you i said i'm in
trouble
and then open it dana taught me this
like don't ever like
sucker punch anybody but open hand [ __ ]
slaps
as hard as you [ __ ] can are really
effective and they've proven to be so
when i was uh when i was getting a
little bit more confident yeah yeah
yeah so i says i'm here and
i hook the first guy and
he goes flying and then the next guy
comes
comes up to me and i i like palm his
face as hard as i can
and then they're like oh my god this
this guy was
you know is crazy let's get the [ __ ] out
of here like they've squared up to me
for a minute
and then they ran off like little
[ __ ] um so
after that like i was like damn i'm
feeling pretty [ __ ] tough like i just
[ __ ] slapped the [ __ ] out of three
three i walked to
uh with my buddies i walked a jet i was
already like
really pissed off because of some stuff
that was going on with uh with my ex
and i see over on the dance floor
and we're like in shorts and flip-flops
like barely getting in
because we we had friends at the door
and i'm like
[ __ ] dude that's that's mike tyson
and my buddy tim is like what and i'm
like dude that's mike right over there
like
[ __ ] look over there and jason's like
no way i'm like dude i'm going over
there
and you're with like 25 huge
guys that look like the guys that you
don't want to bump into on your way to
the bathroom
those are the bounces of the club
no i knew i knew all the bouncers at the
club i didn't recognize any of these
guys
they they're all just stacked in this
table and i'm like
i'm like dude i'm going over there [ __ ]
this i would never
like go up and say hi to like any
celebrity or anything like that
but i was like dude i'm gonna i [ __ ]
have to go up and say hi to him
introduce myself to mike let's just say
he's awesome or whatever so they're like
don't [ __ ] go over there you're gonna
get your ass kicked and these are two
of my toughest friends i was like i
don't [ __ ] care that'd be a good
story
so i walked down the dance they're like
i'm not going with you you're on your
own
and i went i went down there
and uh and i tapped you on on your
triceps i was like hey
hey mike just you know just want to say
i'm a huge fan
and and you know you're [ __ ] awesome
and you started talking to me for like
five minutes you gave me a hug then my
buddies
came down and you were talking to them
you're talking to all of us for five
minutes i'm like dude
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] you know awesome
and i was going through like some weird
boxing [ __ ] cause i was like but all
these ecstasy was good
and then i was like dude thanks so much
for the time really appreciate it
and you shook i was like dude i [ __ ]
love you you shook my hand
and you pulled me in and you go i love
you too brother
and then you [ __ ] were like super
super [ __ ] rad
made my whole night for sure man
yeah see that's a good that's a good
first story man and there's no
there's no celebrity that i've ever seen
that has gone through so many challenges
and come back and so many challenges
come back
and so your journey through life
i don't think you realize how many
people you inspire
in a positive fashion it's [ __ ]
badass
for sure there's no um life is to be
challenged that's the purpose that we
live in life is to challenge
life and um i'm ready for whatever life
has to give to me because
i could take it get like a gift it could
do yeah
yeah for sure no that's what i'd tell
some people that uh
are looking for advice you know for me
it says welcome
challenges with uh open arms and smile
on your face welcome adversary
there's nobody getting out of here free
no
we're gonna go deal with this pain
before we die yeah a hundred percent
i think that's a good note to leave it
on i think it's good enough to leave it
on you have any children man
i got at least two to talk about it you
get a lot of [ __ ]
yeah yeah i like that a lot of fun no um
i got two children i got my daughter zoe
uh
my son jaden they're awesome you know
it's
two different moms you know like
i'm separated um but i got a wonderful
girlfriend
who's uh awesome she takes very good
care of me and she
teaches me how to shoot a little bit
better we have two different strengths
in two different areas
so it's cool it's really really cool
well thanks thanks for having me thank
you man it was an honor brother
super super rad all right this is hot
boxing i'm rashad evans we had guest
bj baldwin and this is mike tyson
i'm signing you off and really bj this
has really been a pleasure speaking with
you really
thank you very much assistant i
appreciate it thank you
we're out of here guys thank you
you